tiene un pasado hicimos un pequeño
repaso acerca de la economía clásica y
luego pues comentamos las ideas que
inicia no es verdad que eran un poco
distintas y pues que tenían mucho
sentido en un contexto en el cual la
economía estaba operando muy por debajo
de su potencial por ejemplo en la gran
depresión verdad pero en realidad en
cualquier momento en el cual la economía
operaba debajo del potencial eran una
buena idea lo que quiero platicar en
este vídeo es como el pensamiento que
inicia no podría ser un poco peligroso
pero antes déjame enfatizar algo las
políticas keynesianas usualmente están
asociadas con un pensamiento político de
izquierda por ejemplo los demócratas en
eeuu sin embargo pues también se ve esto
en algunas partes del pensamiento
político de derecha no sé digamos los
republicanos en eeuu y sobre todo sus
últimas administraciones han realizado
algunas políticas que en el fondo son
keynesianas por ejemplo cuando la
economía reside entonces aumentan la
demanda agregada disminuyendo los
impuestos lo cual contrasta con el
mecanismo demócrata de aumentar el gasto
gubernamental pero finalmente el
pensamiento subyacente es que iniciando
bueno ahora pasemos a un pequeño repaso
de algo que estábamos platicando en el
vídeo pasado que era ese ciclo que
hicimos tenía
teníamos ave hace ya de que no sé son
personas o compañías vélez vende a a a-
le vendía de de le vende hace y se le
vende a ver y así pues por simplicidad
vamos a suponer que cada quien vende dos
unidades de el bien o servicio que
ofrezcan lo que sea lo que decíamos es
que a lo mejor se puede despertar un día
de mal humor pudo haber tenido una
pesadilla y pues de repente puede
decidir que pues no se siente muy bien
acerca del futuro que quiere comprar
menos no más poseer un poco cauteloso
para tener un poco de efectivo en caso
de que lo necesite y pues para hacer
esto pues va a comprar un poco menos de
de entonces le compra sólo una unidad
ahora de no tiene un negocio tan bueno
nada más puede comprarle una unidad y
luego a le compra una unidad de lo mismo
ve que su negocio no está tan bueno le
compra uno hace y en este punto se
siente así como un profeta verdad dice
guau la economía si estaba bien mala
pero ya sabemos que esto sólo fue una
profecía autocumplida el pesimismo de
ese fue lo que causó este ciclo de aquí
ahora las cosas podrían ponerse peor
verdad a lo mejor se puede decir guau
soy
profeta tenía razón con que la economía
se estaba poniendo fea a lo mejor se va
a poner más fea todavía y entonces tengo
que hablar un poco más nada más le voy a
comprar la mitad le voy a comprar media
unidad dejar pongo aquí media unidad y
ahora de eso lo puede comprar la mitad y
el ciclo puede seguir y seguir y la
situación pues puede empeorar y empeorar
hasta que cada quien solo compra justo
lo necesario y pues puede ser que todos
podrían producir más la economía podría
estar más saludable todos podrían ser
más ricos tener más riqueza y entonces
pues esto da que es algo feo verdad este
es más o menos según yo lo que pasó
dentro de la gran depresión o en
cualquier depresión entonces una buena
idea podría ser decir por qué no dejamos
que el gobierno intervenga en la
economía ponemos al gobierno y hacemos
que estimule el ciclo es decir pues ve
estaba comprando uno pero el gobierno va
a decir no sabes que yo voy a comprar
otro entonces te voy a comprar otra
unidad se dice google
muy bien las cosas están buenas voy a
comprar dos desde que emoción de le
compra dos aa comprar dos de b&b ahora
sí ya está bien le compra dos hace
entonces pues ya las cosas regresaron a
su normalidad la economía está en su
estado óptimo en una situación ideal
aquí el gobierno tiene que decir ya lo
logré ya hice mi trabajo puedo deshacer
esto de aquí verdad no quiero
sobrecalentar la economía porque puede
causar inflación si pongo mucha demanda
agregada entonces pues deberían de dejar
de hacer esto el problema y el peligro
es que esto de aquí no es tan fácil de
hacer este estímulo de aquí pues fue
algún tipo de proyecto gubernamental
verdad no sé a lo mejor fue una
disminución de impuestos puede ser pero
de cualquier forma cuando haces una
política de este estilo se digamos que
fue un gasto de gobierno es muy difícil
de deshacer este gasto gubernamental
pudo haber sido de un proyecto que
empleó a muchas personas estas personas
son votantes y no se van a quedar con
los brazos cruzados mientras se cancela
el proyecto entonces existe el riesgo de
que no sea lo mejor si haya una
justificación a corto plazo de la
política keynesiana pero cuando tenemos
que dejar
esa política es muy difícil deshacer el
estímulo como que ya está muy fijo todo
lo que puede suceder es que cuando los
tiempos están malos pues puedes hacer
estímulos keynesianos pero en los buenos
tiempos no quieres deshacer los verdad
entonces eso va a generar más y más
déficit más gasto gubernamental y
entonces pues el gobierno va a seguir
endeudándose esto va a causar que la
economía no esté en su posición más
saludable y el gobierno no va a querer
deshacer esta política porque va a ser
impopular déjame dejar claro que esto es
pues tanto de izquierda y de derecha o
sea los de la izquierda lo que hacen es
decir vamos a gastar más entonces el
gobierno compra más cosas estimula
gastando más pero el impuesto lo dejan
fijo entonces pues obviamente el
gobierno tendría que pedir prestado un
poco más no sé a lo mejor podrían
aumentar un poquito el impuesto pero
esto básicamente es la idea de una
política keynesiana de izquierda estoy
acá sería por ejemplo para los
demócratas de eeuu y entonces se realiza
a través de una política monetaria y por
otro lado con una política de derecha
los impuestos van a disminuir ok y con
eso el gobierno pone en las manos de la
gente decidir dónde se tiene que gastar
más
sin embargo el gasto de ellos va a
mantenerse igual no va a estar tanto y
la gente va a decidir en dónde gastar
también puedes hacer ambas cosas puedes
disminuir los impuestos disminuir los
ingresos y aumentar el gasto esta
política de acá abajo se ha hecho tanto
por administraciones republicanas como
demócratas en eeuu bajan los impuestos y
luego no se es inventando una guerra lo
cual obviamente causa déficits pero
bueno en el fondo puede haber una buena
razón una buena justificación keynesiana
para realizar estas políticas puede que
la economía realmente esté muy por
debajo de su potencial ahora lo malo es
que aunque esté justificada hacer la
política puede ser que no sepas dónde
está el potencial que no sepas dónde
parar y aunque lo sepas puede ser muy
difícil parar es decir puedes seguir
consumiendo mucho aumentar la inflación
y finalmente sale más caro el caldo que
las albóndigas
bueno el otro punto pues malo verdad el
otro punto negativo es que sucede a
largo plazo en el corto plazo esto tiene
mucho sentido verdad vamos a meterle más
ganas a la economía para que el siglo
quede bien pero a largo plazo
esencialmente solo es hacer que la gente
consuma y consuma más usualmente en
países desarrollados puedes escuchar que
en las noticias el presidente o los
políticos dicen vamos a lograr que la
gente consuma más para que podamos
reactivar el ciclo económico lo que casi
nunca se escucha es que van a realizar
políticas para que la gente pueda
ahorrar más para que se pueda realizar
más inversión o sea para que en un
sentido clásico la barra de oferta
agregada se desplace hacia la derecha
eso puede ser un poco peligroso bueno
los eeuu son una excepción tienen una
gran ventaja al respecto el gobierno de
eeuu ha generado un montón de déficit y
entonces se ha apegado mucho a algunas
políticas que inician us y entonces eso
causa que pues los consumidores y el
gobierno consuman más y más la gran
ventaja que tienen es que además tienen
un montón de inversionistas extranjeros
que meten ideas meten inversión y
entonces logran mover la demanda
agregada hacia la derecha y con eso
logran aumentar la producción sin
embargo eso es un gran riesgo para
los otros países que no tienen esta gran
ventaja que eeuu ha tenido como por un
par de décadas mira cuando tienes un
cierto recurso no sé digamos que tienes
un cierto recurso que es el tiempo
entonces puedes dedicarlo uno a cazar
conejos o bien puedes invertir tu tiempo
inventando nuevas formas o nuevos
mecanismos para cazar esto de acá es
cazar y consumir y esto de acá es
invertir en nuevas tecnologías vaya pues
determinar nuevas formas de cazar
conejos de una manera más eficiente
inventar el arco la flecha etcétera acá
es invertir en vez de consumir y siempre
hay que encontrar un balance pero las
políticas que inician as pues consisten
principalmente en aumentar el consumo lo
más que se pueda eso puede ser una buena
idea en el corto plazo especialmente si
estamos operando por debajo del
potencial debajo de lo que puede lograr
la economía pero puede ser un gran
riesgo a largo plazo porque puede causar
su inversión y entonces en un sentido
clásico nunca vas a poder desplazar tus
curvas de oferta agregada hacia la
derecha